The Joe Rogan Experience it takes a lot
of attrition in conditioning and skill
to do that but when guys fight like that
they're doing the complete opposite of
fighting they're doing everything in
their power for them not to land the
blown and me not to land the blowing
it's kind of like bro you're almost
trying too hard to sniff Acro at your
sniff an armpit you know
it's it's fighting but it's also
entertainment you know and he wasn't
finishing guys he's just literally
hugging guys to death you know so my
perspective was I'm fascinated to see
who he can do that to because he did
that to a lot of guys I mean he did a
lot of guys guys that were like killers
and he just put that [__] wrestling
on yeah you know and the beautiful thing
about the way you knocked him out is you
prayed on his instincts you you went at
an angle and then right to him and his
Instinct was just automatically to grab
you I mean that is one of the most
iconic photos in the history of the
[__] sport you know also and you use
that even in your papers let's just show
Let Go Jorge has papers 305 babies
and it says the bottom super necessary
let's go man
as super necessary you get them papers
bro you had a knockout I mean I remember
watching that going oh my God you know a
lot of it a lot of it was uh also
psychological man I I knew from hanging
out that
um
he's like hey you got to come prove it
now something like that I was saying
like all that [__] talking you got to do
it now
any chance they get the fight clock go
to the side and then boom right in
Alcove but the whole thing is though the
walking over him that really gets him to
change his speed I uh I saw that on
Twitter you know he's you know I always
like to study my dudes in different ways
but I saw that enough
sure
it's just celebration on Twitter I saw
that he was very uh like you know witty
and I was constantly writing [__] like
that I'm like you know he's a dork and a
nerd but you know he's got a little bit
of whip behind the computer screen when
I saw him face to face every time and it
was straight my Q versus yours
improvisation versus your improvisation
or maybe you've been thinking about some
stupid [__] for like a month and you're
gonna say to me now but he froze up
every single time and these are like a
lot of encounters we had off camera like
I remember I saw him and I was like
ducked off in in a Conan he had he was
walking by this room like I'm just gonna
spring up on this dude and scared
they're living [__] at him so I did pop
up on him hands me behind my back
literally short circuit hey hey master I
heard you're a very tough guy all right
I gotta use the bathroom and I'm
following no no let's talk but I just
want to talk don't worry I'm not gonna
do nothing come over here let me talk to
you bro why are you such a corny
[__] and I'm just you know
trying to prove at him and I noticed
every single time that it was unscripted
unimprovised like that that just spur of
the moment
shorts are couldn't [__] you know
keep it together so I was like I I not
only need to run at him but I need to
have like a change of speed because
that's going to make him go into his
natural crotch sniffing instincts if I
just change the speed on him he's gonna
[__] duck so that's why I came out
slow cut the little angle and let him
like oh okay you know we're gonna Circle
it up as soon as I change speed what
does he do go to his [__] initial
instincts is a [__] crotch in there
and go sniff the crotch and say you're
gonna kiss this knee goodbye though you
know that was one of the greatest
knockouts in the history of the sport
without a doubt I mean one of the best
ever thank you sir plus it doesn't take
up too much of your time you know you
gotta hey you want to see a dead body
real quick bam you know and it's over
it was just a giant screen and that was
like you [__] launched into him
it was hilarious though like right away
on Twitter he's like well that sucked
and then and then it counted his ass off
you know boom I mean he leaned into it
too I mean he was dying to sniff the
crotch dying bro
he's like he should have been invited to
the Sam bankman freed party
a horrible knockout one of the worst
ever and one of the greatest ever it's
just the way he set it up though so and
then watching video footage of you
practicing that over and over and over
again and knowing that that was a plan
so when I'm doing it the night before
I'm like 95 certain because of the way
he's been acting all week like all I got
to do at any given moment is just
get this guy uncomfortable go from like
chill to invaded space whether it was in
the opening bout or like in the second
round or Midway through the third I just
knew I had the invade his face and he's
gonna go to his Natural Instincts I know
I keep saying it but I just knew it like
the way he'd freeze up every time we
talked the way he'd walk the way he'd
get stiff yeah I mean you literally
practiced the exact same thing over and
over and over again it's so it's so wild
to see